the girag an experience and suboxone
look suboxone helped save me and helped
me get off it but eventually you gotta
get off that too and you kick how hard
is that is it hard to get off it
okay there's something called fentanyl
yes okay which is elephant tranquilizer
it's synthetic
it's like spice like when synthetic weed
okay all these kids in jail by the way
these young kids they smoked this k2
[ __ ]
date and they could they stop while
they're talking to you like a kid will
be talking to you in jail like that jail
jumpsuit and it'll just be like he stops
he looks like he got hit with volcanic
ash or something because they spray
these chemicals on the weed and it does
something to them they start dancing
like Julie Andrews all these Bloods and
Cripps are dancing to the sound of music
[Laughter]
it's really it's weird
so fentanyl is like the heroin version
that it's synthetic heroin yeah much
stronger people are dying from touching
it like they touch you to get you cops
are dying or constant getting overdosed
these guys at the border they're
sweating right it comes from shine and
there's always conspiracy theories about
China trying to kill us and who knows
maybe it's weeding out a lot of junkies
I was in a rehab which I got to give a
shout out to this place turning point in
Paterson is where I really got clean I
was there for three months I did a month
in jail and then I did three months a
turning point a great place they really
helped me out a lot
my counsellor Sarah shout out there but
she you know I got clean there but it
was in Paterson in the hood and the
gangs would fight each other to get the
corner right across from the the rehab
because people would come out yeah
people come out and they get high to
kids I was in there with you know went
and got I they died that day
Jesus they just leave and they died that
day from fentanyl these are junkies if
you get a certain amount of time clean
your your willpower you know your
resistance resistance goes down and so
they would take what they used to take
and a nobody killed they were out that
so to get off the suboxone is is very
difficult because you got a kick it you
got a kick it you know we trolls take
average four to five days and I've done
that in jail twice so if you have
fentanyl in your system
you take us a boxing you go into what
they call precip withdrawals which are
like the regular withdrawals times a
million like you feel you're gonna die
you start to loosen eight this happened
to me twice I went to I went to jail not
knowing that the coke they put it in
everything they put it in the cocaine
they put it into marijuana because they
want people to catch a habit and if a
couple people died cuz if you gotta have
it I gotta keep going back so you're
buying what you think is blow it's not
it's it's blow with this fentanyl in it
heroines Brown with you yes it's brown
when you get it it fentanyl is white so
if it's really a lighter color it's it's
got fennel in it but people want to get
high so bad they take the risk if you're
a junkie I'll take that risk
so I did not know I had fentanyl in my
system it was in the cocaine I had so I
get that I get to jail and I seen his
kid into bulton at the jail and he was a
dealer I knew from the street and he
owed me he owed me a favor and these
kids smuggle drugs and in there in the
band that I rub sweat pants they have it
right here if you see a kid going like
this all the time and kids walking over
to him you know he's got something so I
went over the kid and I said what do you
got and he goes I just got subs suboxone
I said give me one cuz I you know I
couldn't deal with the anxiety and he
gave it to me I didn't know I had Fenton
all in my system I took us a boxing with
it and in ten minutes I was writhing on
the floor Rock just just just so they
threw me in a cell and I had a I had a
kick um I had a kick with those kind of
withdrawals in a jail cell how long does
it last
five days five days not a cos when I was
kicked in an Essex County Jail the coz I
love them they're great guys are tough
[ __ ] they got a tough job and
they were very supportive of me and they
protected me in there they were there
were good guys but um so they were
giving me food they were trying to keep
me hydrated and [ __ ] there was a doctor
that it was really cool but I I was
naked because you're also on a suicide
watch if people kicked from heroin again
all this emotional pain comes back on
you and a lot of people commit suicide
so they give you what they call this
turtle shell that you're naked and you
go on this turtle thing that's like a
Velcro thing so I kicked for five
days in that thing just just rolling
around I started to hallucinate my old
man's been dead for 30 years I could
have swore he was talking to me right in
front of me yeah it's just and then and
then knowing that then I get it out of
my system I get out of jail and I'm and
I and I get high an hour later you know
so you know if if you keep doing that
there's something wrong so what happened
this time that changed I they kept me
away for longer than I ever was
III I was doing I was doing like
two-week bid a week bid in jail this
time
I was in jail for almost two months and
I kicked then I went to a long term
rehab and I got locked away from it and
I started to think clearer and think
about the consequences and think about
my mom and the fact that my mother is
this great Italian woman who uh you know
I thought she just needed money for me I
took care my old man on his deathbed
said take care of your mother and as an
Italian guy from North Jersey you think
that means money doesn't mean anything
else so I kept giving her money not
knowing she was worried about me died
and you know all the time so she's I
thought about her pain and I said I
can't do this anymore
so I just started to think clearer and
then a one-day-at-a-time comes in so wow
that's the difference the difference was
I was locked away from the dope longer
than I ever was so not only did the
physical withdrawals go away but the
mental which was Charlie Parker to great
jazz musician it was a heroin addict I
he was 35 he said they can get it out of
your body but they can never get it out
of your brain Charlie Parker done at 35
Charlie Park was 35 Jesus correct the
Carter said he was 66 yeah but but he
adds the most profound thing I haven't
heard someone say about heroin he said
they can get it out of your brain but
they can get it out of your body but
they can't get it out of your brain
because you remember it yeah yeah I
remember that it's a way to deal with
[ __ ] and it's a maternal thing right
it's like almost like being in the womb
just I didn't I've never done it but a
knee surgery they gave me a morphine
drip coffee
give me a button yeah and today I was in
the hospital I get hit at any time I
want I just hammered that thing yeah of
course you just go just glide off
most beautiful wonderful feelings well
that's the thing about drugs they work
[Laughter]
yeah you know you don't want and again
that's something else in our business
like uh you know I don't want to wait
for anything
you want the money now right I want to
come now I won't get high now yeah I
want to gamble that that's the part of
what makes you a great comic though that
impulsive wildness is what people enjoy
in romick's yeah all my favorite comics
Kennison Joey Diaz yeah all of them
struggled yeah it's it's a prior look of
Richard Pryor yeah when he Bruce Lenny
Bruce Hicks all of them sure Robin
Williams everybody everybody had drug
problems
[Applause]